well I'm joined Now by Israel's
ambassador to the UK Zippy hotovy
Ambassador thank you for coming in it's
I mean it's heartbreaking it is just to
hear one mother I mean and there are so
many there are hundreds and hundreds of
just 199 of the people are now kept
hostage in Gaza and I'm thinking about
young children thinking about uh a girl
that has autism and she's disabled I'm
thinking about Holocaust Survivors I
think we we've never experienced
anything like that as the Israeli people
we experienced Wars we experienced
Terror attacks never in since Israel was
established we experienced anything that
was as barbaric as this human as where
were you when you heard what happened I
was in Israel I was uh staying at my
parents in-law's house and 6:00 in the
morning when the first alarm came we
woke up and I think it was 8:30 when the
second alarm came came in a small City
next to Tel Aviv and I told my husband
this is serious and and from an instinct
feeling because of the sirens going up
and down I had a feeling something
really bad came up and I turned uh my
phone uh on Shabbat and and I I realized
this is a war and I want to tell to
everyone who listens and follows Israel
for many years I think we never had such
a clear event that every country should
protect its people I mean you said it in
in your great opening and and I want to
Echo that this is one of those moments
in a nation's life that a country cannot
carry on without providing the very
basic obligation that every country has
to its people we need to protect our
children we are out there in Gaza not in
order to Revenge not in order to punish
I don't agree with any of those defition
it is partly that though let me just say
why we're doing that we're doing that to
make sure that my children my friend's
children and every child in Israel will
be protected after we've seen what
happened to our border after we've seen
what those barbaric terrorists from
Hamas came in and they beheaded babies
heads I mean the fact that those those
small babies you know we saw in the
telegraph wrapped in uh those bandages I
mean this is something breaks the heart
of every parent and you cannot see that
and the horrific photographs and
everything documented by us the fact
they put children together and burned
them alive the fact they wanted to choke
people in their homes by putting them on
fire those type of barbaric actions and
and I I'll tell you more than that uh
after identifying unfortunately a
thousand 300 Israelis that were brutally
murdered the people were recognizing the
bodies they said 80% of the bodies being
tortured and our president just exposed
a booklet that basically showed that it
was part of their you know way of action
that they wanted to torture the people
it was part of their Terror actions uh
raping innocent young women uh you know
taking hostage a holocaust Survivor I
mean this is really I I saw the footage
of that woman who'd survived the
Holocaust being taken away and all I was
struck by was she was completely calm
she was staring ahead and she wasn't
giving
them a second of of her own feelings in
that moment I thought that was just
extraordinary
given what she had obviously gone
through as a young person but but let's
join uh all the International Community
including prime minister sunuk today in
Parliament that said all those people
kept in hostage must be released now and
I think this is Israel's demand and this
is one of the aims of this war is to
bring them back home 199 and let's also
not be afraid as the BBC is seemingly
afraid to do to call this what it is an
act of Terror these are terrorists I
think we were we were very vocal about
what do what do you feel about the BBC
refusing to call them terrorists um so I
think if the BBC stands for accuracy and
if the BBC stands for um the truth it's
very simple I mean this is what
terrorism is and you cannot find any
better example of terrorism so I I
really think everyone should call it by
its name and it's terrorism and and I
think one more thing we need to to say
uh at this time because Israel is now in
one of its uh I would say this is not
exist exential threat but this is our
war on existence because we cannot exist
if our children cannot be safe in their
homes so Israel Israel has decided and
people will absolutely understand this
that Hamas has got to be eradicated in
the way that Isis was eradicated but
Isis was eradicated in a process that
also involved a lot of innocent people
getting killed on the way clearly in
what is coming now in Gaza a lot of
innocent people on the Palestinian side
are going to die as well
how many is too many and I don't have
the number I just talk about this debate
about
proportionality I'm struggling to see
what is proportionate that meets the
scale of what happened last weekend let
me make that clear I don't have the
answer here but there's a fine line that
Israel is going to tread between doing
what it can to get the hostages
out paying back Revenge retaliation
whatever you want to call it for what
has happened I call it defense I call it
defense I mean whatever you called it
obviously that's part of the motivation
too uh and ultimately you want to get
rid of Hamas but Hamas are embedded with
civilians we know this so the civilian
death toll is going to be very high and
the question for the International
Community is at what point does the high
moral ground which I think Israel has at
the moment because of the scale of what
happened last weekend at what point
could you risk losing that so first of
all Israel is a moral country Works
according to the international law and
according to the international law we
are allowing all the Palestinian Ians to
go to the South area of Gaza in order to
make sure they'll be safe including
creating shelters for them with the
International Community organizations to
make sure they will be safe the only
thing me ask you on this side just just
one say Let me let me just finish the
only thing that stands as a barrier from
those Palestinians to get into a safe
place is the fact that Hamas is
preventing from its own population to
get to a safer place because it doesn't
care about its people he's using
international support not in order to
give them as you said water and
electricity but actually in order to
fire on Israel and as we speak you know
everyone is talking about this horrific
Massacre but sometimes we forget that
fighting from Kamas carries on as we
speak today Parliament being evacuated
the center of Israel being bombard by by
those rockets and we keep having over
6,000 Rockets just in the last week so
think about it it needs to have
electricity and all those manufacturing
what do you think supports that so it's
Hamas basically taking from its own
population and using it against in I
heard I hear I hear you but I also heard
you this morning saying there's no
humanitarian crisis here by any
definition of a humanitarian crisis that
is happening that I mean you may a
portion blame to Hamas on your side let
me explain I don't think you can deny
there's a humanitarian crisis let me
explain that I'm a woman I'm a mother I
have a sympathy to any innocent child
any innocent person in the world we
don't want to harm any innocent people
we want to Target the militants we want
to Target those terrorists we want to
Target the facilities the capabilities
this is what we want to do and the
reason I said that because at the moment
in Gaza you have supplies of water you
have supplies of food and unfortunately
wait a second some of it being some say
the water has run out in many areas and
I want to explain why 90% of the water
in Gaza are not supp is not supplied by
Israel this is like a myth uh Gaza is
Israel has just 10% of this 90% of it is
based on their aquifer and they're doing
that by using um machines and the
machines basically in electricity they
being abused at the moment by Kamas in
order to fire my own Hometown this is
what happened just think how irrational
it is that the International Community
knowing thatas started this war is blame
Israel for what it didn't start it I'm
not blaming Israel no no all I'm saying
is I I I understand the scale of what
happened last weekend means that there
must be an unprecedented response
exactly I think any country in the world
that suffered what Israel suffered last
weekend would launch an unprecedented
response I understand that but I also
understand in my modern history that
after 911 America launched a series of
unprecedented responses it invaded Iraq
which I felt at the time was an illegal
Invasion that caused Isis to grow in
huge amounts of power and then kill many
many people Afghanistan was a huge mess
and continues to be a mess and is now
back in the hands of the Taliban and so
on there's not a lot of evidence that a
big invasion of a place like Gaza will
do anything other than potentially make
the situation worse that's my concern so
can can I give you uh my answer life is
about choosing between between
Alternatives um if you have a perfect
alternative you would have gone for the
perfect alternative but going back even
for British history I you don't want to
go back to American history by attacking
mosul and killing so many civilians and
I I personally think uh fighting Isis is
a Justified cause because Isis didn't do
any good uh for for civil civil and and
going back to your own history when you
fight Nazi Germany you knew that there
were many many civilians got attacked
from your attacks on German cities
dresen was a symbol but you attacked
Hamburg you attacked other cities and
ALT together it was over 600,000
civilian Germans that got killed and was
it worth it in order to defeat Nazi
Germany and the answer was yes let me
ask you just to just to finish my point
is we don't Target civilians we
definitely give them an alternative and
a place to find a shelter and we are
trying to minimize casualties because
our Target is just to remove Kamas from
our border in order to have my children
to sleep peace and quiet in their
bedroom I understand but it is also true
that nearly three times as many
Palestinians have died in the last week
than were killed in the outrage on
October the 7th and then that number is
going to go much much higher so this is
exactly why I think it's unmoral
equivalence because those people got
killed in Israel children women and men
were brutally targeted and murdered in
the most barbaric no no but the people
got caught in a crossfire in Gaza are
people we didn't want to kill some of
them are terrorists you need to remember
that and we are targeting those cruel
people that are based in schools based
in hospitals and according by the way to
the international law Israel is allowed
to launch a military attack every time
there is a place that is puts Israelis
in danger which it is the facilities of
Hamas are based in civilian fa do you
feel you talked about being a a mother a
parent do you feel on a person personal
level genuine sympathy with the innocent
Palestinians who are getting caught up
in this absolutely I mean my my thoughts
are to every single individual that is
caught in a war zone now but but but you
need to understand every country has
first and foremost responsibility to its
own people so if Israel will fail to
defend my children and other people's
children like we've seen those parents
that had to you know be in a shelter
hearing other like I will never forget
this video that you hear parents that
here one of their children get executed
I mean this is those are things those
are things are totally horrific so when
this is the reality you need to
understand there was a a misconcept of
of the understanding that Kamas can be a
tarer can live by you no this tiger it
it it went out of of the cage and it did
what it did and it's a barbaric action
how do we get to peace after this so
that's a great question I think um you
cannot have peace I mean this again
going back to your history you cannot uh
have any type of negotiation with this
type of barbarism that is based on
Jihadi ideology Hamas Charter is calling
to enation of Israel and total
Destruction so it it it has no political
Vision so we need to have uh from the
other side we need have people wants to
leave peacefully with Israel we've seen
the Arab worldl uh opens the gate to
Israel we've seen the Abraham Accords
we've seen Saudi wants to normalize with
Israel I believe the future can be
better without Terror organizations and
this is why Israel is fighting this war
by the way for the West as well this is
not just Israel's fight this is the
Western world's fight just like you had
your attacks in 77 the Manchester Arena
it's the same type of ideology that
attacking innocent people and we need to
fight it together it is inarguable
finally that before this attack the
plight of the Palestinian people in Gaza
was completely unacceptable many will
see the control that Israel has wielded
in the last week as evidence that it's
unhealthy control over the people of
Gaza and indeed potentially of the West
Bank as well my next guest will
certainly be arguing that very strongly
that until what they see as the
oppression of the Palestinian people is
properly dealt with that they will
always be this kind of I mean you can
call last weekend what you like to me
it's a disgusting Abomination but there
will always be angry people in Palestine
wanting to break out of what they see as
oppression what do you say to that um
let's just check the facts from 2000
actually actually Gaza was the uh case
study for how the world will look
without Israeli control on Palestinian
uh area and territory 2005 Israel
withdraws to the international border
and people believe that Gaza will become
immediately Singapore and look what
happens so actually it's the other way
around from 2000 2005 Israel doesn't
have any settlements doesn't have any
territorial demands from the
Palestinians instead of turning Gaza to
a Flor City they took all the
international support and there was
massive support and they took it to to
build this underneath tunnel City that
became a terror City and evil city we
saw the results in its ugly face on last
Saturday you wouldn't deny that the
living conditions of people in the Gaza
Strip for example have been completely
unacceptable and Pierce who should we
blame for that Israel doesn't control
the Gaza Strip 200 Isel is Israel
blameless I would say that Israel after
it's not blameless I would say Israel no
country in world is perfect but after
2005 you need to blame the effective
control of Hamas uh that abused the
population that kept on using all the
international support just for one cause
to harming innocent Israelis to fire all
those rockets that been fired on our
cities for years by years and this is
where every civilized person should
stand and to say we saw the real face of
Hamas on Saturday they are there to kill
innocent Jews in their beds and we need
to support Israel in this Justified
fight because Hamas is bad both to
Israelis but also to Palestinians
Ambassador thank you very much and for
coming in and just going back to what
happened last weekend it was horrific
and when I saw that the instant reaction
on the streets of this Capital City
London were thousands of people out in
the streets celebrating some of them
with Hamas Flags I was revolted that
that was happening in my country and the
the only correct response to what
happened then was outrage and it's been
disgusting to watch people celebrating
what happened to your people so thank
you for coming in I appreciate it well
thank
you